speaking of women's issues the house on
friday passed legislation that would uh
make
abortion a national right now i know
that abortion is already legal
at the national level but that's only
because the supreme court invented a
pretend imaginary constitutional right
to abortion in roe versus way it was
affirmed in planned parenthood v casey
but it's not actually a law
so because now there are these wonderful
work around pro-life laws in texas
there's one coming up in florida they're
going to be others i hope
the house democrats passed a law
saying that and look this this law is so
preposterous i don't see any way in
which it's upheld
unless of course the libs just
really clamp down on their power they
throw logic out the window which they've
been known to do before but
what they're saying is there now there's
a national right to an abortion
up until the moment of birth everywhere
in the country
okay
this is called the women's health
protection act it doesn't protect the
health of the female babies who are
being slaughtered
roughly half of the babies but it's the
women's health protection act it was
approved by the house 218 to 211. so
this at least was more of a party-line
vote
faces tough odds in the senate i don't
think it's going to go anywhere in the
senate but who knows you know it's up in
the air
the
the way that they're thinking about this
law is more interesting than the law
itself
because the measure states that health
care providers have a statutory right to
provide and patients a right to receive
abortion services without these
limitations okay so this is this is from
the bill
since 1973 the supreme court repeatedly
has recognized the constitutional right
to terminate a pregnancy before fetal
viability and to terminate a pregnancy
after fetal viability where it is
necessary when it's necessary in the
good faith medical judgment of in the
good faith judgment of someone whose job
is to kill babies okay of the treating
health care professional for the
preservation of the life or health of
the person who is pregnant not of the
woman because it's not women anymore
it's the person who is pregnant the good
faith medical judgment of someone whose
job it is to kill babies i don't think
they have a lot of good faith do you
feel safe when you're browsing the
internet
you should not you should if you if you
do feel safe if you don't realize
there's even a problem then you
especially should not okay
just to use one example payment apps
like venmo cash app and others they make
payments easy but
you might want to adjust those privacy
settings to prevent them from sharing
your personal information a recent
report found that payment apps share
user data with third parties including
banks fraud monitoring services some
even share it with marketing firms it's
very important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every single day every second
almost of every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats such as your
social security number for sale on the
dark web you've got access to a
dedicated restoration specialist if you
become a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com knowles
that's lifelock.com knowles for 25 off
what this does in practice even though
it says there might be some limits on
that in practice it says there is no
limit because if the mother says you
know i might get a little depressed if i
have to have this baby then you can kill
the baby up till the moment of birth
second part many abortion specific
restrictions do not confer any health or
safety benefits on the patient well it
confers some benefits on one of the
patients namely the baby who's being
killed and third this is the the
craziest part
i know
that's uh saying quite a lot given how
crazy the rest of the bill is says
congress has the authority to enact this
act to protect abortion services
pursuant to a its powers under the
commerce clause of section 8 of article
1
and its powers under section 5 of the
14th amendment okay so the reason this
is so crazy is
congress should have no right to do this
this is not an interstate matter this
should be a matter for the states right
at least according to the commerce
clause but they're saying well because
abortion exists in multiple states it's
an it's interstate commerce so we can
regulate it but then the craziest part
is they cite the 14th amendment equal
protection under the law what about the
equal protection of the babies actually
the 14th amendment makes a strong
argument for banning abortion nationwide
but they don't care this is the
radicalism that we are talking about
this this would have been unthinkable in
the democratic party even i don't know
four or five years ago it would have
been unthinkable but that's how far the
country's moved to the left and they've
done it with some mild opposition from
republicans but largely they've done it
with the tepid support of the so-called
conservatives i'm so glad you liked that
clip but hold up i need your help on
something
sometimes you may have heard about this
the social media
companies the they don't
they don't love what we say okay and so
one way that we fight back against
censorship is making sure that people
have access to the direct stream the
audio podcast okay you can get that at
apple podcast spot if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcasts just type in the michael
knowles show subscribe there maybe you
listen there maybe you watch it on
youtube maybe i don't know whatever you
want to do subscribe there make sure you
got access
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you